تفجير ببصمه تنظيم الدوله ولايه خرسان
الهدف هذه المره بالقرب من وزاره الخارجيه
والرساله الملطخه بدم القتل والجرحى لمن
في كابول وخارج افغانستان الضحايا كلهم من
موظفين الوزاره تزداد وتيره الهجمات
الانتحاريه في البلاد بالرغم من الغارات
التي تشمها قوه الامن ضد مسلحيه تنظيم
المعادي لحكومه الطالبان دشنت افغانستان
اول يوم من السنه الجديده بالتفجير نفذها
انتحاري على الدراجه الناريه امام المطار
العسكري بالعاصمه لا يبعد المطار سواء 400
متر عن مقر وزاره الداخليه سقط فيه 10
قتله والجرحى ديسمبر الماضي كان مؤلما على
ضحايا هجوم مسلح على فندق يرتاده الصينيون
الصادمه لبيدين قالت قوه الامن الافغانيه
حينها انها قتلت ثلاثه من المهاجمين على
تنظيم الدوله في ولايه خرسان مسئوليته عن
الاعتداء تنظيم يصف التوسع الاقتصادي
العالمي لبيج بالالامبرياليه الصينيه
ويرفع سقف تهديداته بعد كل تقارب بين
حكومتي كابول وبيجين استقبلت افغانستان في
مارس العام الماضي وزير الخارجيه الصيني
في زياره هي الاولى منذ عوده طالبان الى
الحكم وحبله بالرسائل الاقليميه والدوليه
الصوره لمصلحه حكومه تعاني عزلتا وعقوبات
دوليه تقودها الولايات المتحده وبالنسبه
لبيدين فهي جوله لكسب مزيد من النقاط ضد
واشنطن ومشروعها الفاشل على مدى 20 عاما
في بلاد الافغان
ببراغماتيه تتعامل الصين مع حكومه لا
تعترف بها رسميا ولكن تصر على علاقات وديه
معها عنوانها المعلن المساعده في اعاده
بناء افغانستان من بعض تفاصيلها تامين
استثمارات جديده
فضحت الروح في مشاريع متوقفه مثل السئف
العمليات في منجم بولايه لوجر تكرار هجمات
التنظيم الدوله بدعم من ولمصلحه من قائمه
مخاوف الافغان وعمومهم تطول عقوبه دوليه
وانتقام التنظيم المتشدد لا تجف دماء
تفجير حتى ينفذ الذي بعدها